Now, this is our solution.
First, Alice and
Bob agree publicly
on a prime modulus
and a generator.
In this case, 17 and 3.
Then Alice selects a
private random number,
say 15, and calculates 3
to the power 15 mod 17,
and sends this result
publicly to Bob.
Then Bob selects his
private random number,
say 13, and calculates 3
to the power 13 mod 17,
and sends this result
publicly to Alice.
And now the heart of the trick.
Alice takes Bob's public
result and raises it
to the power of
her private number
to obtain the shared secret,
which in this case is 10.
Bob takes Alice's public
result and raises it
to the power of
his private number,
resulting in the
same shared secret.
Notice they did the
same calculation,
though it may not
look like it at first.
Consider Alice.
The 12 she received from
Bob was calculated as 3
to the power 13 mod 17.
So her calculation was the
same as 3 to the power 13
to the power 15 mod 17.
Now consider Bob.
The 6 he received from Alice was
calculated as 3 to the power 15
mod 17, so his calculation was
the same as 3 to the power 15
to the power 13.
Notice they did the same
calculation with the exponents
in a different order.
When you flip the exponent,
the result doesn't change.
So they both calculated
3 raised to the power
of their private numbers.
Without one of these
private numbers, 15 or 13,
Eve will not be able
to find the solution.
And this is how it's done.
While Eve is stuck grinding
away at the discrete logarithm
problem, and with
large enough numbers,
we can say it's practically
impossible for her
to break the encryption in
a reasonable amount of time.
This solves the key
exchange problem.
It can be used in conjunction
with a pseudorandom generator
to encrypt messages between
people who have never met.